bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de parlement hebdo en compagnie
de michaël szames est bon jour michael
dans l'actualité politique et
parlementaire cette semaine il ya eu
l'élection des présidents de conseils
généraux troisième tour des élections
cantonales la gauche se retrouve à la
tête de 60 départements et gagne un
candidat aux primaires du parti
socialiste françois hollande
l'ump se déchire autour du débat sur la
laïcité son secrétaire général jean
françois copé s'en prend au premier
ministre qu'ils accusent de ne pas jouer
collectif
de leur côté les représentants des six
grandes religions de france publient une
tribune où elle dénonce les conditions
du débat
enfin nous reviendrons sur ces sénateurs
qui détricote les textes votés à
l'assemblée en commission ils s'opposent
au durcissement du texte sur
l'immigration modifications aussi du
texte sur la bioéthique est avec nous
sur ce plateau hervé novelli bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
vous êtes députée ump d'indre-et-loire
plus connu comme étant de fibre libérale
vous avez d'ailleurs créé un courant au
sein de ce parti majoritaire qui
s'appelle les réformateurs vous avez été
secrétaire d'état du gouvernement de
françois fillon en charge du commerce de
l'artisanat des petites et moyennes
entreprises et à ce titre on vous
connaît notamment pour être à l'origine
d'une démarche qui a créé beaucoup
beaucoup de monde sur le sur le marché
qui s'appelle les auto entrepreneurs
m'étais va être une grande fierté pour
moi
alors vous avez quitté le gouvernement
fillon en novembre dernier vous est
maintenant secrétaire général adjoint de
l'ump vous y représentait donc l'ère
libérale comme on a dit pendant que
l'autre adjoint marc philippe daubresse
représenterait plutôt la tendance
centriste jean françois copé a voulu
montrer la son respect des courants au
sein de l'ump qui est sûre quand même et
il le fasse il est même possible
d'exister aux côtés de jean françois
copé exister médiatiquement et il a
une notoriété une aura médiatique qui
est indéniable mais j'ai parfaitement
trouvé ma place je crois auprès de lui
je me concentre surtout sur des débats
des propositions je suis plutôt un homme
de réflexion et de proposition et là
j'ai toute la place il vous écoute je
pense oui
ce qu'on a vu vous parlez de médias
c'est vrai qu'au temps du temps de
xavier bertrand il y avait deux
porte-parole qui a assuré les points
presse
là c'est ici les son propre porte parole
on vous entend guère aux écoutes et en
tant que sport on a même évoqué par
exemple basse et des stadiers que les
deux derniers points après je n'étais
pas là parce que j'avais des obligations
politiques à bruxelles et puis et une
autre dans ma province pour
l'enterrement de jean royer je tenais à
être présents pour cette grande figure
tourangelle donc je n'ai pas été mais
rassurez vous je serai là mercredi au
prince au point de presse avec les
élections cantonales suite et fin
le résultat final des élections
cantonales la gauche possède désormais
60 départements contre 40 à droite voici
donc la nouvelle carte des départements
de france
une élection marquée par des surprises
lors du troisième tour
ce troisième tour c'est l'élection des
présidents des conseils généraux les
explications de thomas souliers voici la
nouvelle carte des conseils généraux
soixante départements dirigés par la
gauche
grâce aux victoires dans le jura et les
pyrénées-atlantiques et 40 par la droite
qui a conquis le val d'oise pas de grand
gagnant au final le ps attend son
objectif est la majorité présidentielle
résistent bien notamment dans la loire
et la savoie où hervé gaymard a été élu
du côté des personnalités à noter
l'élection demain les sols touraine en
indre et loire
elle est la seule femme nouvellement élu
du côté des centristes maurice leroy
gare de son siège en loir-et-cher et
françois sauvadet en côte-d'or tout cas
bravo à tous ça c'est une belle victoire
un grand merci mais aujourd'hui tous les
regards étaient tournés vers lui je
gainey est élu président ben ali alors
que le ps vient de lancer une commission
d' enquête sur d'éventuelles pratiques
frauduleuses dans les bouches du rhône
jean noël guérini est réélu président le
nouveau janot elle est née à l'instant
où je vous parle
cette campagne a été parfois très très
très très dur exaspérante
on faisait un personnage de -1
véritables bandits quelqu'un de
fréquentable et cetera et croyez moi que
je suis le perçu un personnage
totalement différent face aux
accusations
jean-noël guérini a décidé de lever le
pied il ne dirigera plus la fédération
ps des bouches du rhône hervé novelli
c'est un vrai recul pour la droite au
niveau local on peut pas dire autre
chose aujourd'hui c'est irréversible
pour votre parti c'est à une défaite
mais regardez les chiffres aujourd'hui
en anna démonstration que tout ce que
disent elles ps à savoir ses espoirs de
d'enlever dix départements au total et
au final on en gagne un et il en gagne 2
voilà la réalité arithmétique et sarsat
john quand même une au niveau local
absolument il s'agit pas de nier la
défaite
nous n'avons pas fait un score égal à
nos attentes mais pour autant nous avons
bien résisté c'est du reste le même le
thème de votre reportage
il ya des coins quand même hein comme en
savoie par exemple ou hervé gaymard du
haut de ses 51 ans
et président au bénéfice de l'âge oui il
y avait plusieurs départements qui
étaient qui avait plusieurs départements
qui étaient là en balance et bien la
droite a gardé deux départements en
balance et voilà c'est un soulagement
c'est plutôt bien résisté mais ça ne
doit pas nous exonérer d'une réflexion
sur les conditions de cette élection
marquée par une abstention massive donc
un désarroi une désaffection un
désintérêt marqué aussi par une poussée
du front national qu'il ne faut pas
négliger même si au final il y a deux
conseillers généraux du front national
abstention selon vous elle était due
uniquement aux modes de scrutin
aujourd'hui pour les départements où
c'est une abstention qui devient
finalement un vrai parti il y à un
désintérêt pour une élection cantonale
qui n'était pas couplée avec une autre
élection cette fois ci et on voit bien
l'intérêt de la réforme territoriale et
de l'émergence de ce conseiller
territorial qui sera à la fois
conseiller régional et conseiller
général
ça c'est indiscutable un désintérêt pour
cette élection qui a vieilli et il y à
aussi bien sur les conséquences d'une
crise qui dure depuis maintenant près de
quatre ans d'une crise économique
majeure pour n'a jamais connu depuis des
années 30 d'une dune d'une montée du
chômage de la souffrance sociale dans
notre pays comme dans tous les pays de
l'union européenne et donc une amertume
un désarroi une désaffection qui se
traduit par un recul des positions du
parti de gouvernement comme ça se passe
aussi partout en europe la crise peut
expliquer vraiment l'abstention c'est la
crise qui explique les difficultés et
qui fait en sorte que ces difficultés
elles se traduisent par des
comportements électoraux dont on sait
bien qu'ils ne sont pas favorables au
pouvoir en place quel qu'il soit partout
en europe le pouvoir en place
recul et j'allais dire d'une certaine
manière c'est assez logique
rappelez-vous wiston churchill pendant
la guerre et tout de suite après la
guerre il a été débarqué et donc parce
qu'il était associé à 7 à cette période
difficile et où notre défi il est de
faire en sorte que l'année prochaine
lors des échéances majeures
eh bien nous puissions continuer à
réformer notre pays dans la sérénité
mais avec l'obligation de le faire
un mot peut-être de jean noël guérini
prévu qui se dit président ps du conseil
général des bouches du rhône qui se dit
un homme nouveau maintenant qu'il a été
élu c'est un peu c'est un peu risible
c'est un peu risible surtout de voir la
défense du parti socialiste de jean noël
guérini alors voilà il ya eu un rapport
puis il ya eu un deuxième rapport de
monsieur montebourg qui d'habitude est
un peu plus écoutée au parti socialiste
qui ne l'est aujourd'hui et là on se
dessine la fura annonce qu'elle sera
d'une troisième puis on aura peut-être
une quatrième une cinquième
moi je vais vous dire mon sentiment est
ma conviction c'est que on manque
sacrément de transparence dans cette
fédération
pour dire les choses de manière aussi
anodine que possible à l'evo clore ce
chapitre des cantonales on va se pencher
sur le cas des hauts-de-seine à l'ump
patrick devedjian a été élu à la quasi
unanimité faut dire qu'il était le seul
candidat
un dénouement qu'il n'aurait pas
envisagé il ya quinze jours même dans
ses rêves les plus fous mais voilà le
clan sarkozy qui s'opposaient à lui
s'est effondré électoralement la journée
d'un survivant comme il se qualifie
lui-même
c'est un sujet de germer andrieu et
yoann heure-là il y a une semaine
presque personne n'aurait misé sur sa
réélection à la tête du conseil général
des hauts-de-seine
aujourd'hui pourtant l'élimination de sa
rivale isabelle balkany a changé la
donne seul candidat à sa propre
succession dans le camp majoritaire
patrick devedjian savoure son retour en
grâce est à la tête du département
ces dernières semaines la presse
a gentiment moqué mangou pour une
célèbre chanson de gloria gaynor devenu
l'hymne de l'équipe de france de
football
victorieuse à will survive patrick
devedjian rescapé a reçu deux jours plus
tôt le soutien officiel du chef de
l'état je pense que tous ceux qui ont
annoncé ma mort dans la presse peuvent
aussi avoir de ce point de vue là un
sujet de réflexion l'adversité il y a
des gens que ça stimule et il ya des
gens que ça dissuade
ça dépend des tempéraments ironie du
sort quelques minutes plus tôt le vote
et la désignation du futur président
viennent d'avoir lieu devant le fils
cadet du chef de l'état
secrétaire de séance durant cette
campagne fratricide jean sarkozy n'avait
pas choisi le camp de patrick devedjian
rabibochage express devant les caméras
ou les deux hommes s'affichent côte à
côte
jean sarkozy quittera la présidence du
groupe ump au conseil général contre un
poste de vice président les apparences
sont sauves à présent la république
aussi a souhaité que dans ce département
comme ailleurs se réalise l'union de sa
famille politique et je crois que c'est
normal
affaire classée ou presque à l'assemblée
locale une partie de la droite fera
désormais cavalier seul jean christophe
fromantin maire de neuilly
triomphalement élu face à une candidate
ump et arnaud de courson tombeur
d'isabelle balkany à levallois ont
décidé de créer leur propre groupe
politique
l'élection de nicolas de sarkozy à la
tête de notre pays a rendu un certain
nombre de personnes à la fois ambitieux
et orphelins
je pense que ça crée un certain nombre
de tensions il serait bon d'être sage et
de penser à nos habitants face à une
droite qui doute une famille de gauche
toujours minoritaire mais conforté dans
les urnes qui ironise sur le drôle de
feuilleton des cantonales ce qui se
passe en ce moment c'est là que tout
continue comme avant c'est à dire c'est
une fois de plus tout se prend les
ordres se prennent à l'elysée
pas de changement au sommet mais la fin
d'un monopole pour l'ump dans les
hauts-de-seine la victoire de la droite
n'a pas été celle du conte sarkozy ben
ali vous a vu sourire veut notamment
voyant jean sarkozy on apprend très tôt
avaler des couleuvres en politique je
souriais parce que je sais nerfs en
peluche souriez parce que j'étais
surtout heureux delà de la victoire de
mon ami patrick devedjan mais que je
connais depuis longtemps et dont moi
j'admire à la fois la grande culture le
sens de l'humour et la capitale est
lâché par nicolas résiste asie par
définition le chef de l'état d'autres
choses à faire que de s'occuper d'une
élection fut-elle dans l'est dans les
hauts de seine
même quand son fils il est présent il
est il regarde ça d'un oeil peut-être un
peu plus attentif mais là tout est bien
qui finit bien super dure bataille quand
même pour le 92 ça fait longtemps que ça
dure avec isabelle balkany notamment
saisi elle a été défaite dans son propre
canton
oui c'est vrai et je dois dire que me
moi je suis très heureux que patrick
puisse aujourd'hui présidé aux destinées
de ce beau département
est ce que la marque sarkozy était un
handicap ans au scrutin
faut bien se garder de d'attribuer des
défaites à telle ou telle cause
personnelle et il n'ya eu un recul je
mets 10 et cela a touché des conseillers
généraux sortants dont lui-même dans le
92 hervé novelli est ce que vous pensez
qu'il ya un rejet du système nicolas
sarkozy voire peut-être de l'image de
nicolas sarkozy on l'a vu dans les
sondages récemment
ce qui est sûr c'est que je leur disais
je disais tout à l'heure qu'il ya une
grande déception
et cette grande exception elle est liée
à la crise mais elle peut s'incarner
dans le candide
à nicolas sarkozy devenu président il
n'y a rien d'illogique cela tout notre
défi tout le défi de nicolas sarkozy il
il est capable de le relever bien suivre
le défilé de faire en sorte que ces
électeurs qui ont voté pour lui en 2007
et qui se sont détournés
à l'heure où l'on se parle puisse
revenir voter pour nicolas sarkozy et ça
j'ai la conviction que cela est possible
c'est la faire à la fois du gouvernement
du président et des partis qui le
soutiennent ces résultats l'ump est bien
est dans tous ses états à chaque semaine
donc ces querelles au sein de l'ump
après le ni-ni revoici le débat sur la
laïcité c'est jean françois copé
secrétaire général de l'ump qui ouvre le
feu et il leur reproche rien moins qu au
premier ministre son manque
d'enthousiasmé pour ce débat qui a lieu
le 5 avril il accuse même d'en faire une
posture en ce mardi
c'est l'heure des contre-feux chèrement
andrieu l'expliqué son texte a eu lieu
avant le conseil des ministres à la
sortie pas un mot pas un commentaire sur
le duel au sommet de l'ump la majorité
est encore sous le choc de la tacc de
jean françois copé contre françois
fillon lorsque vous lui posez la
question maire monsieur fillon vous
craignez pas la stigmatisation dans un
débat sur l'islam et qu'au lieu de vous
répondre mais monsieur aphatie on a vu
tous ensemble avec le président
république avec copé ce sera sur la
laïcité
ce sera positif non il répond pas ça il
vous dit juste à monsieur aphatie si
c'est pour stigmatiser l'islam je m'y
opposerai aider les arbres dans la
majorité et bien permettez moi de vous
dire que lorsque ce type de croire de
choses est présenté ainsi on a envie de
dire mais attendez on peut pas jouer
collectif une fois un règlement de
compromis ram et surtout la suite
logique des tensions internes qui secoue
l'ump depuis l'entre-deux tours des
cantonales quelques minutes avant la
réunion du groupe majoritaire
la crise est enfin reconnue par le
gouvernement kenyan gilad oui ça on est
lucide bien effectivement
engueulades maintenant là encore le
message qu attendent de nous les
électeurs s'est pas tapé vous sur la
tête je trouve que le moment où on a
besoin d'unité
le fait de s'attaquer au premier
ministre quand on est secrétaire général
de l'ump s'est pas responsables
finalement jean françois copé décide de
jouer la carte de l'apaisement mais
présente des excuses en demi teinte
j'ai tout à fait bien volontiers admis
que sur la forme il pouvait être perçu
comme excessif mon sujet pas de problème
avec ça en revanche sur le fond ce que
j'ai souhaité c'est mettre les pieds
dans le plat parce que encore une fois
je le répète les lendemains d'élections
ça doit aussi servir se dire les choses
à l'assemblée ces rivalités agace à un
an de l'élection présidentielle les
parlementaires de la majorité appelle à
resserrer les rangs pour 2012 je pense
que après tohu bohu d'hyères que ce soit
le président de la république le premier
ministre et de ce que tu en général d'un
autre mouvement arrive en quelque sorte
à mieux gérer les thématiques à mieux
gérer les différences n'étant que
j'allais dire de signer un cessez le feu
ce qui compte maintenant c'est la
prochaine élection les cantonales c'est
fini tournant la page
un voeu pieux a confirmé pour éviter
l'implosion de l'ump dès demain françois
fillon recevra les députés les plus à
droite de la majorité avec un seul
objectif affiché l'apaisement alors vous
qui est l'adjoint de jean françois copé
vous allez pouvoir nous éclairer quelle
mouche a donc piqué jean françois copé
pour s'en prendre à sciez au premier
ministre et en plus à la télévision
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu un énervement
fort de la part de jean françois copé il
a du reste reconnu mais ce que voulait
dire jean-françois on en a discuté c'est
que nous nous sommes engagés dans la
feuille de route
le cahier des charges de ce que ce qui
nous a été fixée c'est à dire jusqu'aux
élections présidentielles faire un
certain nombre de propositions qui vont
alimenter le programme du candidat à
l'élection présidentielle de notre camp
c'est ça la feuille de route de l'ump et
dans cette feuille de route il y a bien
sûr certain nombre de débats qui ont été
programmés parce que ces débats sont
autant de noeux qui sont posés à la
société française et dans ce cadre il y
à toute une série de calendrier qui sont
fixés et on ne peut pas choisir à la
carte
on ne peut pas dire celui-là ne me plaît
pas celui là me plaît celui là on verra
c'est un projet présidentiel que nous
souhaitons contribuer à proposer aux
candidats notamment de discipline et il
s'en prend directement à son premier bia
et bien il a été excessif mais il
voulait dire que nous devons nous
rassembler il y à des débats pour
lesquelles on a plus ou moins
d'appétence moi le premier mais je ne
vais pas dire je n'irai pas là parce que
ça ne me plaît pas et ça n'intéresse pas
non chacun doit trouver sa place
le gouvernement est engagé dans une dans
une oeuvre de production de résultats
lors des deux résultats sur l'option
économique et l'ump dans une oeuvre de
propositions voilà la rémission non sur
canal + 7 est improvisé ou préparer à
l'avance prémédité on va dire je n'en
sais rien
je suis proche de copé mais pas au point
qu'il me donne ses pensées les plus
secrètes et c'est naturel a trop chaud
que nécessaire mal pour un bien on déjà
tandis que le lendemain le premier
ministre et le secrétaire général de
l'ump ont convenu que l'incident était
clos et qu' il fallait se rassembler
mais sa voie le jour décidé qu'un
incident décréter qu'un incident au clos
santé lieu de venir c'est rien de le
faire et je crois que ce sera le cas
tant les deux divisions mortels dans des
palois le couple par exemple fillon copé
c'est presqu'à duo impossible il ya des
couples qui se déchirent mais qui se
retrouve dans tout cela dans tous les
domaines de la vie et là ils ont je
dirais besoin l'un de l'autre
le premier ministre il a une tâche à
accomplir avec le gouvernement sous
l'autorité du président de la république
c'est que nous ayons des résultats sur
le front économique
sur le front social qu'il y ait un
certain nombre d'actions concrètes
qu'ils soient menées durant cette année
c'est là qu'on l'attend on l'attend
moins sur les débats le gouvernement on
l'attend moins sur les propositions pour
l'avenir et donc il y avait un une
répartition des rôles
il était bien que le secrétaire général
de l'ump face la clarification qui
s'imposait au gouvernement d'obtenir des
résultats dans l'année pour bien
préparer cette échéance et aux parties
de faire des propositions pour le de la
2012 voilà il est quand même assez
critiqué au sein de la majorité on a vu
cette tribune qui a été publiée cette
semaine dans le monde par laurent
wauquiez et 50 députés de la droite
sociale c'est quand même pas mal qui
critique la gestion ou partie ça vient
quand même très vite parce que c'est un
jeu de secrétaire général et c'est vrai
et moi de mon poste j'observe que ans il
n'a pas eu droit à une période d'essai
comme on dit c'est à dire que ceux qui
ont été écartés
parlons clair ceux qui ont été écartés
de la direction précédente se sont mués
en opposant déterminé à vous pensez que
la direction du parti
voilà la réalité et je le regrette pour
ça je pense que la raison devrait ce qui
appelle à la raison ferait bien eux
mêmes d'être raisonnable par exemple
l'ancien de l'ump était là dans votre
reportage dont vous les avez reconnus ou
lait pas cité je ne veux pas faire de
2,2 des limitations à dominer mme c'est
pas mon mon propos mon propos il est de
dire que aujourd'hui leur doit être
rassemblement et non pas à la pilot nage
systématique de celui que le président
de la république a souhaité voir à la
tête du parti le plus important de la
machine un peu de débat c'est bien sûr
il faut des débats
non mais moi je suis pour l'aider à ne
pas être tout à fait d'accord avec vous
avez tout à fait raison alors on
l'expriment par exemple à la tribune en
disant je ne partage pas telle ou telle
option
moi j'adore les débats j'adore les
débats sur les idées sur les
propositions qu'il faut faire pour notre
pays sur la manière de sortir de cette
crise et ça c'est bien
c'est intéressant par contre débattre
sur l'opportunité d'un débat que nous
avons et poussant les débats
collectivement décider et bien voilà ça
montre malgré tout qu'il ya un peu plus
de petites manoeuvres que de grandes
convictions mais ce débat sur la laïcité
il en est encore question voilà que les
responsables religieux sont mêlés les
représentants des six grandes religions
de france ont publié mercredi dans le
parisien une tribune commune dans
laquelle ils s'interrogent sur
l'opportunité d'un débat dans le
contexte actuel il se demande également
si c'est au seul parti fût-il
majoritaire ne conduire ces débats une
réaction oui moi je comprends
là la réaction des églises ou des cultes
je la comprends parce que et eux aussi
ont des choses à dire et mais on ne peut
pas dénier aux partis politiques dans
leur ensemble et allume mp en
particulier le soin de débattre aussi de
la place des religions dans la cité et
de l'organisation de notre république
parce que vous le savez très bien et ça
ne sert à rien de le cacher de se
dissimuler la loi de 1905 elle a été
faite en 1916 j'avais écouté tout de
suite d'autres réactions recueillies à
l'assemblée nationale nous nous
considérons qu'un grand parti politique
qui débat du pacte républicain est que
dans la république tu as des éléments
constitutifs c'est la laïcité peut avoir
quelques raisons de prendre d'organiser
un débat là-dessus à condition qu'il y
ait à la clé des propositions concrètes
et constructives
le judo c'est très dangereux parce qu'on
a la loi de son sac et surtout très
inutile parce que si elle débouchait sur
quoi sur une constatation que la
république était laïque elle est laïque
qui est sûr c'est que voilà elles sont
plus laïque ces religions la queue que
président de la république et ça pour
moi c'est très important
vous avez entendu jean glavany et ce
sont les religieux qui appelle au
respect de la laïcité c'est un peu un
comble c'est un paradoxe mais notre
république est laïque simplement cette
loi de 1905 on peut peut-être
s'interroger sur le fait de savoir si
elle est aujourd'hui particulièrement
profondément adapté à l'émergence de la
seconde religion pratiquée en france qui
est l'islam qui est intervenu bien après
celles ci pour la liste raymond des
prochains oui j'y serai j'y serai un cra
et forcée ou non pas du tout je suis un
terme général adjoint de l'ump et il est
naturel que je sois à toutes les
conventions
il y a je dois y aller franchement
journée des choses
je n'irai pas oui bah ils ont s'ils ont
autre chose à faire et dieu sait si au
gouvernement on a des choses à faire et
bien libre à eux de ne pas s'y rendre
le premier ministre et il est premier
ministre il déjà il n'est pas venu aux
conventions précédentes et on comprend
que sa charge le dispense de venir
participer à des débats formation de
l'élection présidentielle s'il vient il
est bien sûr le bienvenu il est chez lui
à l'ump roselyne bachelot s'il ya
d'autres occupations cet après-midi-là
ya l a fait elle a dit qu'elle n'irait
pas et par contre bruno le maire valérie
pécresse luc chatel baroin
françois baroin vient il doit animer une
table ronde a priori mais en même temps
il dit qu' il répète ce qu'il a dit il
est pas pour ce débat donc soyons précis
françois baroin a coprésidé la
préparation de ce débat j'étais moi-même
à ces réunions préparatoires et saufs
hallucinations j'ai bien vu françois
baroin discuter avec nous de
l'organisation de ce débat
ce que voulait certainement exprimé
françois baroin c'est que ce débat se
terminera mardi par des propositions et
qu'on passera un autre débat des
propositions de quelques propositions
très concrètes nathan attendez il ya
plus beaucoup de temps à attendre mais
on aura des propositions concrètes bien
sûr parce que là pour le coup on ne
comprendraient pas qu'il n'y ait pas des
propositions sur la nécessité
d'organiser mieux telle ou telle
pratique dans les lieux de culte la
formation des imams ce genre notre show
là tout cela sera vue
et passer en revue et il y aura un
certain nombre de propositions mais pour
y avoir assisté à ces réunions
préparatoires qui se sont déroulés
vraiment avec beaucoup de beaucoup de
sérieux et de travail
je pense qu'il y aura des avancées très
intéressante pour que finalement tout le
monde vive mieux dans notre république
parce que c'est ça qui est posée et il
n'y a pas forcément de raison de toucher
à la loi de 1905 si par ailleurs on ne
prend pas délicieux on peut prendre des
dispositions d'ordre législatif au sens
d'une résolution par exemple
parlementaire qui réaffirme arrêt un
certain nombre de presse de pratiquer
qui d'une certaine manière pour
réactualiser sans avoir la force d'une
loi mais la force d'une résolution
puisque c'est une des modifications de
la constitution
cela peut être une avancée il y en aura
il peut y en avoir d'autres
je crois qu'on a fait du travail sérieux
le financement par exemple des cultes
religieux absolument il eut heureusement
oui il y aura des des discussions
là-dessus et il faudra passer en revue
toutes ces difficultés y at il ou pas
suffisamment
trop ou pas suffisamment de lieux de
culte dans notre pays ça nécessite
d'être vu sérieusement parce que nous
avons besoin dans notre république d'un
rassemblement et de la liberté de la
liberté de conscience et de la liberté
de croire ou de ne pas croire comme ont
un peu de mémoire on se souvient quand
même que ce débat au départ ça plaît
débat sur l'islam vous comprenez qu'il
puisse y avoir des inquiétudes de
dérapages c'est notamment ce que disait
françois fillon oui il peut y arriver il
peut y avoir inquiétude lorsque on la
pointe du doigt soyons clairs il y a eu
beaucoup d'arrières pensées dans les
dénonciations qui nous veillerons à ce
qu'il n'y ait aucun risque et notre
volonté est de faire de cette réunion
sur la laïcité et la place de l'islam
dans notre république une réunion pour
le mieux vivre ensemble
je crois que nous y parviendrons et
après je vous annonce qu'il y aura un
grand débat sur
la compétitivité de notre pays mais
l'auto mais ce sera plus sûrement et que
j'anime il y aura des propositions
fortes mais je crois que l susciteront
un débat un bon débat comment les amis
justin avec ce débat sur la laïcité
il a été un petit peu réduit à la
portion congrue ça va être maintenant
deux heures dans un hôtel parisien dites
moi si je me trompe 2h02 table-ronde a
aussi fait ce gars désir tout ça pour ça
non il faut se garder de tercica tueur
et voilà un débat qui a suscité des
tonnes et des tonnes de commentaires
et maintenant on nous dit bon bah
c'était pas la peine de le faire mais ça
fait des semaines et des semaines qu'on
débat entre nous sur ce débat est sûre
sur les propositions que nous tiendrons
ces tables rondes
ce sera très sérieux parce que ça ça
vient ponctuer et conclure une
préparation très intense avec beaucoup
d'audience beaucoup d'auditions et je
crois beaucoup de réflexions et de
propos latéral et ceux qui vous disent
c'est toujours la course à l'échalote
derrière le front national ce genre de
débat on fait aussi parti qu'est ce que
vous répondez
je réponds que on met en exergue ce
débat il y en aura deux autres j'ai
parlé de celui que j'animerai il y en
aura un autre sur la justice sociale
il y en aurait su sauvegarder sur la
défense il peut se trouver que le front
national dénonce tel ou tel point
il nous appartient à nous partie
responsables et partis de gouvernement
de faire des propositions pour ne pas
laisser au front national le monopole de
la dénonciation sans proposition ce qui
est la pire des choses mais nous
proposerons à chaque fois que nous
débattrons et ainsi nous démontrerons
que il ya d'un côté la dénonciation que
porte le front national et de l'autre
l'absence de propositions flagrante du
parti socialiste bref nous avons
vocation à faire toutes ces propositions
dans les semaines il y en a besoin de ce
débat la loi bioéthique est étudiée en
commission par le sénat
mercredi le vote récent par les députés
de la loi bioéthique en première lecture
avait été dénoncée par les scientifiques
comme une régression la commission des
affaires sociales du sénat a décidé de
corriger le tir dans un sens plus
libérale elle ouvre par exemple la voie
à la recherche sur l'embryon les
explications de flore sauvages
oui à la levée de l'anonymat des
donneurs de sperme et d'ovocytes et oui
à la recherche sur l'embryon sous
conditions la commission des affaires
sociales du sénat fait évoluer en
profondeur le texte de révision des lois
de bioéthique votée en première lecture
par l'assemblée nationale
il me semble que la petite loi telle
qu'elle est sortie de l'assemblée
nationale
on n'a pas fait beaucoup de progrès par
rapport à l'existant et que l'on peut
essayer de la faire avancer
et sur la recherche sur l'embryon sur la
question des mères porteuses ou sur la
levée de l'anonymat des donneurs de
gamètes
les sénateurs quelle que soit leur
appartenance politique ont des avis
divergents sur certains points
extrêmement important on se rend compte
que le clivage n'est pas droite gauche
mais qu'il s'agit vraiment d'une
interrogation d'une interpellation de
chacun de nous face à lui même pour le
ministre de la santé xavier bertrand qui
est venu défendre son projet de loi la
réunion de groupe ump hier matin il
n'est pas nécessaire d'avoir une
révolution en matière de bioéthique
je crois pas qu'ils n'attendent de
révolution en termes de bioéthique
pourquoi parce que je pense qu'on a
aujourd'hui une situation qui répondent
aux valeurs auxquelles on croit la
disponibilité la non marchandisation du
corps humain et je pense que ça permet
aussi à la recherche d'avancer
les discussions devraient être animés la
semaine prochaine dans l'hémicycle
l'examen du projet de loi débute mardi
en séance publique lors d'une veillée on
le voit les sénateurs ont été encore une
fois un petit peu plus audacieux que les
députés notamment sur bâtir bioéthique
c'est très bien c'est très bien ça
prouve l'utilité et le caractère
indispensable du et de deux chambres
dans les institutions de notre pays et
j'espère et je pense qu'on trouvera cet
équilibre que cherche qu'à chercher
l'assemblée nationale et que et que
cherche différemment le sénat entre
d'une part la protection l'intégrité de
la personne et d'autre part la nécessité
de faire en sorte que la recherche dans
notre pays ne soit pas c'est très
important début que certains cherchent
pas absolument et il faut absolument que
nous soyons au même niveau en matière de
recherche que nos principaux partenaires
concurrents et c'est bien qu'il y ait
débat sur des sujets aussi complexes que
la levée de l'anonymat est aussi un
thème compliqué je suis favorable à tous
les débats vous devriez celui là comme
tous les autres bien c'est parfait
impasse au jeudi
quand françois hollande se voit
doublement président
en ce jeudi dont françois hollande est
réélu dans son fauteuil de président de
conseil général de corrèze et sans
perdre minutes il fait ce qu'il avait
promis
il se déclare candidat aux primaires du
parti socialiste
un corrézien qui guignent l'elysée et
l'allemand jardy clone du phare sa
candidature n'est pas une surprise mais
c'est maintenant officiel françois
hollande se lance dans la course aux
primaires socialistes
ici à tulle devant vous mes amis j'ai
décidé de présenter ma candidature à
l'élection présidentielle à travers la
primaire du parti socialiste
une annonce qu'il a choisi de faire
annuler son fief devant des élus et
militants socialistes par le vrai pari
aux corréziens et je suis sûr qu'il
apparaît en france et comme il parle aux
corréziens brillantissime comme
d'habitude on y croit et on va tout
faire pour justement que ces chansons
puissent aller jusqu'au bout je déclare
la séance du 31 mars 2011 ouverte
quelques heures plus tôt françois
hollande a été réélu à la tête du
conseil général de corrèze
cette victoire le socialiste on a fait
l'étape indispensable pour poursuivre
son chemin vers 2012 à 20 voix contre 17
monsieur françois hollande était le
président du conseil général de la
corrèze l'occasion
pour le candidat de profiter des
conseils de bernadette chirac
l'ancienne première dame élu au conseil
général françois hollande espère être en
route pour l'elysée pour l'instant
direction paris un passage au journal
télévisé ce soir et dès demain premier
déplacement de campagne à
boulogne-sur-mer
c'est vraiment parti pour 2012 que vous
inspire françois hollande comme
potentiel rival de celui qui sera votre
candidat attend dé pied parce qu'une
ancienne la course d'obstacles oui et
entamé voilà ce que ça m'inspire c'est à
dire que on voit la pléthore des
candidats socialistes et je me demande
comment et dans quel état l'un ou l'une
va arriver après cet exercice a plu
importe peu parce que quel que soit le
candidat selon les sondages nicolas
sarkozy arrive loin derrière
oui enfin gardez vous de penser que les
sondages donnent la vérité un an avant
l'élection mais il ya surtout quelque
chose de paradoxal c'est qu'on prépare à
un programme pour l'ensemble des
candidats socialistes à dire que le
candidat socialiste est là pour aller à
la télévision ânonner le programme du
parti socialiste c'est quand même bien
une bizarrerie et il faudra qu'il s'en
explique
chaque candidat et j'imagine les
candidats aux primaires socialistes
doivent avoir leur projet et je leur
souhaite bonne chance pour
l'harmonisation qu'on leur qu'on leur
propose
alors que les sondages ne sont pas très
bons pour nicolas sarkozy finalement
elle vous arrange ses primaires
socialistes je vais pas vous dire que ça
me fait de la peine c'est très bien
qu'ils ces primaires et je le dis je
suis curieux de voir vous savez la
droite est là elle a essayé d'inventer
un système comme cela ça n'a jamais
marché n'a jamais marché
eh bien on verra si cela marche mieux
au parti socialiste ce qui me soucie
beaucoup plus c'est le vide sidéral des
propositions aujourd'hui du parti
socialiste quels que soient les
candidats ou la candidat
on attend avec intérêt parce que si
c'est pour nous refaire le coup des
emplois jeunes et des 300000 emplois
jeunes de 1997
sadate sadate et donc sur son voisin
avec la présentation de vers l'avenir
que vers le passé comme semble le faire
le parti socialiste on voit ce qui se
passe au sein de l'ump en ce moment les
tensions attendues parfois que de bonnes
primaire serait peut-être pas mal au
lieu de présenter comme ça directement
un candidat unique il serait peut-être
nicolas sarkozy c'est le président de la
république est le candidat naturel de
son camp s'il décide de se représenter
ça se passe comme ça sous la vème
république il a pu y avoir des
contestations sont très ouverts il ya eu
des contestations par le passé mais
aujourd'hui la réalité c'est qu'il n'y a
pas d'alternative il n'y a pas
d'alternative ouverte officiel et c'est
cela qui est important or une
alternative ça se construit ça ne se
révèle pas au détour de telle ou telle
petite phrase à un an de la
présidentielle
on le sait bien et tout le monde en
convient ce sera notre candidat parce
que c'est le seul qui puisse nous mener
à la victoire
évidemment jean louis borloo il doit y
aller pour vous c'est à lui de le dire à
l'élection et les lignes mais moi je
considère qu'aujourd'hui il y a un
besoin de rassemblement qui est plus
fort que le besoin de se différencier
sur compromis mais bien sûr parce que
jean louis borloo a accompagné le
président de la république dans son
action depuis le début de ce quinquennat
et donc sur quoi sur quoi va-t-il faire
campagne sur le fait de se différencier
alors qu'il a été l'un des plus proches
de nicolas sarkozy mais n'empêchait
visiblement quitté l'ump au mois de mai
nous verrons bien
moi ce que je souhaite et je m'entends
très bien avec jean louis borloo qui m'a
toujours soutenu dans mes initiatives
ce que je souhaite c'est qu'il trouve
toute sa place à l'intérieur de notre
famille politique mais là dessus il ya
des désaccords au sein de l'ump on a
mieux compris jeudi le texte immigration
texte phare voulue par nicolas sarkozy
après son discours de grenoble et
détricoté par les sénateurs de
disposition introduite par les députés
qui modifient l'accès à la nationalité
ont été supprimés mais françois fillon a
promis aux députés qu'il aurait le
dernier mot
une nouvelle bataille parlementaire aux
perspectives alexandra colinot c'était
un projet emblématique pour le
gouvernement le sénat a choisi de
retoquer une partie du texte sur
l'immigration en commission des lois
exit donc l'amendement voté par les
députés restreignant le droit au séjour
pour les étrangers sans papiers malades
exit aussi la disposition introduite par
les députés de la droite populaire qui
supprimait l'automaticité de
l'acquisition de la nationalité pour les
jeunes étrangers de 18 ans a considéré
que c'était une remise en cause du droit
du sol qui est une tradition française
parce que ça aurait pu concerner des
enfants nés en france n'ayant jamais
quitté le pays depuis 18 ans ne parlant
que le français ayant toutes leurs
relations en france et piquet aurait dû
justifier leur demande de nationalité
française à l'âge de 18 ans après la
poussée du front national au premier
tour des cantonales et le débat au sein
de l'ump qui en a découlé
la majorité sénatoriale souhaite faire
entendre ces divergences ne faut pas
donner l'impression qu'on court après le
front national pour ne le combat pas
forcément en prenant les mêmes positions
que lui on le combat rne en affirmant
ses propres nos propositions sur ce
texte le sénat a choisi de se poser en
rempart contre les excès du pouvoir
si appréciable que à la commission des
lois malgré le
la ténacité en quelque sorte négative de
l'assemblée nationale il sera il reste
sur le consomme au dos sur leurs
positions c'est à dire qu'ils veulent
pas pour pour employer une expression un
peu familière ici veulent pas en
rajouter le projet de loi sur
l'immigration sera examiné en deuxième
lecture en séance publique le 12 avril
prochain
hervé novelli la droite populaire c'est
à peu près une cinquantaine de députés
qui ont été reçus par françois fillon
cette semaine obtenu gain de cause on
dit toute façon ça sera retoqué à
l'assemblée nationale cette droite
populaire c'est devenu l'alpha et
l'oméga de l'ump non la réalité c'est
que c'est l'assemblée nationale qui dans
notre constitution a le dernier mot
et donc si si l'assemblée nationale
persiste dans le texte qui a été voté à
l'assemblée dans sa propre lecture est
évident que c'est ce texte qui sera
adoptée par contre ce qui est sûr c'est
que la droite populaire exprime une une
vérité à l'intérieur de notre groupe un
attachement aux valeurs dites
régaliennes d'autorité et de sécurité
pour les gens dont beaucoup en ce moment
on les entend beaucoup et c'est très
bien les expriment une sensibilité et ce
qui est bien c'est qu'il y ait d'autres
sensibilités qui exprime elle aussi une
autre réalité par exemple est libre ce
sont les sénateurs qui vont le plus à
l'encontre des volontés gouvernementales
la chambre haute à la une tradition
de sérénité mais aussi d'indépendance
moi je m'en réjouis mais de quel
parlement pourrait-on être fiers s'il
n'y avait pas cette volonté de peser sur
des textes au sens de ses convictions
c'est ça qui est très important je ne
suis jamais mais content lorsqu'il ya
des débats y compris des débats qui
peuvent avoir recelé des divergences
entre à l'assemblée c'est la petite
réaction peut être rénové lisent sur ses
déclarations de georges tron le
secrétaire d'état à la fonction publique
qui affirmer qu'il y aura une remise en
cause du dogme du non remplacement d'un
fonctionnaire sur deux d'ici 2012 non le
répond françois baroin ça ne sera pas ça
rien ne change au moins jusqu'en 2013
c'est quoi c'est à nouveau couac au sein
du gouvernement ce qui est très
important c'est la maîtrise des dépenses
publiques
et on sait que dans cette maîtrise des
dépenses publiques c'est le poids du
nombre d'agents de la fonction publique
et le plus important y compris pour les
retraites on a on n'en parle pas
suffisamment et donc je pense qu'on doit
avoir cette maîtrise de la masse
salariale des fonctionnaires et de leur
nom je trouve cette avancée un peu trop
vite pour vous je pense que georges tron
s'il propose un système alternatif qui
permettrait par exemple de s'interroger
sur la pertinence d'une action publique
exercer et pourquoi ne pas la transférer
au privé
dans certains cas il en a visiblement
pas parlé à françois bayrou il aurait
pété messieurs gibus qu'une initiative
mais mais je crois que l'essentiel c'est
aujourd'hui après 2012 de s'interroger
sur les fonctions de l'état dans les
lycées sur ces mots que nous allons nous
quitte et merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous pour commenter cette semaine
d'actualité
quant à nous michael nous nous
retrouvons la semaine prochaine va mieux
même heure au revoir